the ginger beard of knowledge here and
we're going to take a look at one of the
Great's and his five most amazing moves
of all time Gary oh gee Kaspar off make
sure you like this video now and we're
going to move over to those amazing
moments and moves now this first example
was played against to pawn off another
brilliant player and we have Gary with
the white pieces he used to love
attacking and ripping his opponent's
king apart and in this position he does
just that rook takes d4 and this
obliterates the pawns around blacks King
these pawns at the moment do defend the
black King but now White's rip them
apart gets rid of that protection what
can black play well if black swaps
Queens White has won the safe porn
so to part off takes the rook Gary is
now four points down but he has another
blow that hits the pile of hard rook to
e7 check who needs rooks anyway just
throw them away the black queen is
controlling that square but we're trying
to use a bit of divergence to move that
Queen away so for example if black takes
the rook which you did not do then Queen
takes d4 leads to checkmate all because
of the b6 square King to b8 pretty much
forced Queen to b6 check and now the
knight slides into this square and
eventually the Queen delivers a kiss of
death checkmate
very nice sequence of checks they're
after rook to e7 what can black do well
black now decides to march forwards
other options also very bad and now the
King hunt starts Queen takes d4 check
and in this position the King keeps on
marching winning a lot of material as it
does take in another night on a5 but we
bring that King further into our
territory
b4 check King's way for an hour lovely
quiet move we don't always need to bring
out the shotgun moves we can also do the
quiet and delicate moves
a bit like a sympathy of chess magic
Queen to see free and now with Queen to
be free checkmate
lingering over blacks King black is
defenseless and went on to lose a very
beautiful game from Gary let's now move
on to the second example
now hopefully a number of you guys
watching this will bear the spot the
following idea it's white to play and
the black king is rather precariously
placed there so how can we force our way
through to deliver a devastating check
against that king think violence what
would an original gangster do Gary
Kasparov rook takes c8 the point behind
this move we're getting rid of the
knight that could have defended on e7
black actually resigned here because he
saw Queen take CA would be met by this
lovely delicate swinging move Queen to a
free check and this of course will win
the game so very nice and simple a
tactic there did you spot it well let's
see if you can get the next one well
chess is all not crashed bang wallop
checkmate as much as we'd enjoy it to be
that way we often have to combine a bit
of crashing with a bit of positional
play and this is what Gary does in the
following position he's playing sheer
off and Gary has established a big night
in the center of the board this is what
we call an outpost but black is getting
ready to eliminate that Knights with
chances of equality Gary now plays a
beautiful concept rook takes b7 now the
rook is worth five points the bishop
free so is clearly sacrificing two
points and for what reason well after b4
we can see his positional idea number
one his knight remains on this square
there's nothing black can do to ever get
rid of this fantastic piece it can't be
attacked by a pawn it can't be
eliminated by a bishop and with the move
before white is also really restricting
the possibilities of the knight on b7
that Knight can't get back into the game
so this is a long-term long-term
positional idea that was so of
tibbe but a very very nice concept how
many people would give up points in such
a way which doesn't have an immediate
goal but a longer effect on to example
number four another customer of Gary's
was Nigel shorts Nigel short paid out
Gary on many occasion and this is no
exception in this position Gary were the
white pieces and this next move again
has some beautiful subtlety behind it
which ends in a dynamic attack can you
see the move here that will open up the
black King the black King looks quite
safe but Gary was an expert of opening
up those cans the cans of beans getting
a little getting a little opener out
give it a little open let's get to the
king Oh yep checkmate there we go
what did white now play Bishop to h6 and
this is an amazing idea because you're
sacrificing on an empty square
philosophical in nature even this has to
be taken and what is the idea well now
we bring in the big guns
Queen to d2 the Queen is sliding into h6
with Queen to g7 as the major follow up
and even though Gary sacrificed a piece
here there's no good way that black can
defend pawn to f5 is a defensive try
that nigel went gave a go but it didn't
work after pawn takes pawn on pass whole
capture in passing and now the bishop
has to move and queen takes h6 nigel
tries ripped away 7 to get some
defensive ideas along the 7th rank but
now another white piece dives in Knight
to g5 and with ideas of f7 coming up
black is helpless and he goes on to lose
in quick time so I really like that
subtle start to a deadly attack another
beautiful example he's playing Gary's
playing he who is he is the big og is
playing against India's finest ever
player and ants with the white pieces
here he sacrificed a rook but the next
move has a theme we've already seen now
to try and help you
find Garry's move let's just think what
white could be trying to play here well
he could try Queen to h5 to try to come
into the f7 square but black always has
g6 blocking the check so Gary found a
way around this little sliding move into
the oblivion Bishop to h6 this move is
quite astonishing as referring the
bishop into the same squares we just saw
in this case we're trying to eliminate
the pawn on g7 for example if black now
takes the bishop we don't even need to
take the Queen there's a better idea can
you see the idea Queen to h5 check
followed up with Queen to f7 check mate
and in the game black tribe Queen to see
free but now white is able to eliminate
the g7 pawn bishop takes g7 with a major
fret or Queen to h5 Vichy tribe Queens
Rd free in order to block that check but
after Bishop takes H a that Bishop has
rampaged enough and now Gary goes on to
win as the black King is just too
exposed in the middle of the board I'll
be back with more beautiful moves very
soon
Aglio look at these videos
[Music]